ja die Weihnachtsmärkte machen wieder
auf Scheißding es gibt in Deutschland um
die 3000 Weihnachtsmärkte mit mehr als
150 Millionen Besuchern pro Jahr warum
der Grund ist ganz simpel saufen pro
Jahr werden in Deutschland unfassbare 50
Millionen Liter Glühwein getrunken weiß
irgendjemand woraus die Plörre aus
diesen warm halteeimern besteht
wahrscheinlich größtenteils aus
Pinselreiniger und den Resten die noch
vom letzten Jahr drin waren ein Becher
davon zerstört so viel Gehirnzellen dass
man auf einmal so ein Scheiß kauft und
gratis dazu gibt so schlimme
Kopfschmerzen dass man sich fühlt wie
der Heiland am kfreitag am besten nimmt
man direkt dazu eine Handvoll Aspirin
denn es dauert normalerweise höchstens 3
Sekunden oh ah Gott oh Gott mein Kopf